Namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma sambudassa
Namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma sambuddhasah Namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma sambuddhasah Homage to the Buddha, the Blessed Noble and Fully Self-Enlightened One.
You'll all know about our, or my,
struggle with the mole, Morris.
And after all my travail, he finally just left.
No matter what I did, he decided to leave when he wanted to leave.
And recently, of course, you've seen me chase the chicken.
So this is the chicken.
Yes, we've, Mark's very, you know,
gone along the fence with all these other fencings, but the chicken gets through.
And even now, I found us all wandering around the garden.
So to me, of course, this is a very good example of our defilements.
And no matter how much we try to get rid of them, they keep bouncing back.
So I think it's a case of accepting the chicken at some point.
And eventually, just that, you see, it dies.
It will pass on.
Just as a small excuse on my part, last retreat, Letta was here.
She's a professional gardener.
And she planted all these seeds, you see.
And when she saw the chickens, she said, well, it's going to be all those seeds.
So that's why...
I've been making this effort to make it feel quite unwanted.
Not with any hatred in my heart, you understand.
There's no version.
So, yeah, lots of questions, actually.
I didn't realise they'd piled up.
The first one is, you know, to do with this indulgence in pleasure, just leading to suffering, the process of it.
we just have to grasp the essential mistake the essential mistake from the heart's point of view is that it's seeking happiness in the wrong place there's nothing wrong with seeking happiness everybody wants to be happy and this seeking happiness is coming from that within us which will eventually achieve the great happiness which is Nibbana
But of course that which is seeking Nibbāna is itself deluded or else it wouldn't be in this mess.
It's a paradox.
It is deluded.
It's fallen from a state of not knowing into a state of knowing.
But that knowing we call delusion.
And the mistake is that happiness is to be found in the sensual world.
by sensual world we mean this physical body and mind the physical body, the mind, the heart and what it can give us with its contact with the outside world so we enjoy beautiful views if we didn't have eyes if we were blind we wouldn't be able to enjoy that so all our enjoyment is based upon the body including the brain as you know when the brain begins to malfunction
you know, dementia or Alzheimer's, then you also lose that capacity to even, seemingly, to even think and to image anything.
So all our pleasures, you know, on this planet, on this earth, are dependent on the body itself.
And so seeking happiness is always through the body and what it does to the heart and mind, right?
Which, in Buddhist understanding, is something separate.
It's another form of energy, we can say.
the Buddha talks about the mind made body as opposed to this physical body and the disconnect between the suffering of pleasure and the joy of it is because the one comes after the other and therefore people don't often make that connection especially with boredom so we have this phrase variety is the spice of life so what we do is we keep seeking for the next
you know, the next input that's going to make us go back to that original place where we felt happy.
So you go on holiday, it was a great place, you want to go back.
You go back, you know, it's not quite what it was, you get bored, so you come back, and then you think there's somewhere else to go.
So if we look at our lives as this constant movement towards what's going to really make us happy, lift us emotionally and intellectually, you know, if we're that way inclined,
and the boredom that comes from it but we don't see that the boredom is actually a product of pleasure itself because product of the relationship we have to pleasure because no pleasure can give us the same buzz we always have to you know either increase it or find something similar to it or give it a break you know I mean if you were eating all the time become really boring
But the fact that we wait until the body signals some sort of appetite allows us to re-enter that pleasure syndrome.
And of course not everything we eat has the same lift for us.
So some food we eat we hardly even notice.
It just passes through down into the throat.
It's just eating for eating's sake.
So I mean that sort of mindlessness comes because of this compulsive behavior of seeking happiness in food.
Seeking happiness in sex, seeking happiness in holiday.
It doesn't matter what it is, it's just that's where you form this habitual, this habit.
And what we don't see is that pleasure and the joy that we get from pleasure has an inbuilt obsolescence.
It's like in the, I think it was in the 60s and 70s, they talked about making sure that machines had inbuilt obsolescence.
so that there'd be a turnover of manufacture.
It was quite openly talked about.
Now, of course, it's very unecological and not very green.
But in those days, you thought, well, we'll make a car to last 10 years, full stop, 15 years, and then you've got to sell it.
So the machinery of manufacturing just kept churning over, whereas they knew they could build cars for 50 years or whatever.
I mean, they are getting better, I believe.
But anyway, it was that sort of mentality that in a sense mirrors our seeking happiness in the sensual world.
That not recognizing that boredom is a product of that indulgence is a big problem.
You know, especially in rich countries where pleasure is easily attainable.
and I'm not talking about rich but I'm just talking about the fact that you can just flick a switch and you're being entertained and what it does is there's a deeper malaise because what it does is it always associates happiness with excitement and when you get too excited you don't mind a bit of silence a bit of quietness a bit of loneliness but actually it doesn't last very long and that's why silence
aloneness and solitude are things that people don't don't develop anymore see a lot of people well I won't say a lot but many people who come here who enter into this sort of sound atmosphere find it difficult I'm not used to it so there's that underlying
frenetic energy of always, you know, like, always seeking the next buzz, right?
What are you going to do on Saturday?
Where are you going?
What are you doing next year?
What were you doing when you retired?
It's always, like, what are you going to do?
What are you going to do?
You know, it's like, do you remember that animal, I think, what's it called now?
Oh, that Rudyard Kipling cartoon, you know, with the elephant and the jungle boy.
Yeah, do you remember the crow?
It was crows, wasn't it, on the branch?
on the branch, and they had this sort of cockney thing going on, like, what are you going to do then, where are we going to go?
I thought it was brilliant.
So, now that's the sort of more subtle disconnection that we have with that emotion of boredom, which remember, in its success, I mean, it leads to real deep depression, a sense of meaninglessness.
You know, in the end, nothing
is giving you that buzz so your life becomes sort of meaningless it becomes really empty and then there's the others which I think a bit more obvious you know grief at the loss of something that you're attached to yearning for something is sort of a you know an incredible yearning that can never be satisfied a sense of lack frustration when you don't get it anger
and this constant underlying anxiety, you know, about losing what you've got.
So there's a heck of a lot of suffering underneath indulgence.
I mean, suffering's bad enough.
You know, dukkha, dukkha.
The ordinary pain and pressure and stress of life, you know.
Just listening to a program there, teachers have a 40% higher suicide rate
than any other any other sector I mean that's stressful isn't it so that in a sense is you know that sort of encapsulates it and then in a sense you can just you know draw that out and the thing is to take it into your own lives when you feel bored at something you stop and say hold on see what's what this boredom is telling me how much how dependent I am on excitement on distraction on variety
now how are you going to overcome boredom?
so the only thing you can do is exactly what the vipassana is telling you is to get in contact with it right but and here's the trick you keep doing what you're doing keep doing what you're doing and as the boredom begins to fade away it transforms into interest and you can try that out in fact that's one of the things I really
thank my father for, because when I was a kid I used to learn how to play the piano.
I remember saying to him, which is really boring dad, you know, you go dee dee dee dee, and he said to me, he said, don't worry son, he said, just keep playing it, you'll see.
And, you know, I kept doing it, and of course suddenly you're playing the tune.
And the boredom had gone then, you know, like we were all excited to play this little tune.
So,
The answer to boredom is not variety.
That's exactly what people think.
I'm bored, what am I going to do?
What's the next thing I can do to make myself excited?
The answer to boredom is repetition.
So as soon as you find yourself being bored with something, you keep doing it with your attention on the boredom, but with your attention on the boredom, so you know it's there, you're not trying to repress it, but your intention is to keep doing what you're doing with goodwill.
Yeah, that's the answer.
Is there any comment on that?
Anybody had that sort of experience?
Yeah?
Good.
No?
No, right, okay.
No, that's good.
Good.
Yeah.
Yeah, well, if your life's busy, if your life's busy and you're interested and involved, then yes, it doesn't particularly arise.
Oh, well, that's a gift.
That's a gift, you see.
Yeah.
Well, it might be, of course.
But if it...
You know, just to spend some time of the day, that's right, just to spend some time of the day in that, you know, abiding in the present moment.
And to keep doing it in little bits every day, all the day, all day long, just to keep stopping.
In between jobs, you know, just stop.
And just abide in the present moment.
And all the time you're drawing yourself down into this calmness.
And you get a taste for it.
That's how you want to be.
You want to be calm.
Just take your time.
Take the rush out.
It's quite difficult to do.
I find that quite difficult to do at work.
Yeah.
I want you to hurry up.
Do what you're doing.
Well, I suppose it's a case of
not getting up their nose but sort of pretending to hurry up but you just carry on you just carry on doing what you're doing you know all right yes okay yes you spoke of painful difficult mental states
and to just observe the mind this seems difficult when in daily life at work especially say with resentment and obsessions any guidance please yeah when you're actually in the process or work or engagement then yes it is difficult it's more difficult than obviously just sitting here still and just observing the feeling as it comes up but
even so we have to be to open you know sort of relax just relax your awareness around things and just notice that's the noting you say ah there's this negative feeling this resentment or obsessive stuff you know and if you're aware of it it doesn't have power over you that's the big understanding if you're aware of
some compulsive behavior or some anger or something in that way of being quite you know being aware of it I mean there's a little distance between you and that feeling then it doesn't have power over you but as soon as you move towards it of course then it begins to affect your behavior so
yeah when you identify with it so it really is a case of practicing just like here we practice you know so in ordinary daily life as soon as this stuff comes up see it as a way of practicing and of course we fail of course we you know keep falling into the old ruts and the old habits but you just keep you keep working with it you see keep working with it and eventually I think it becomes
Well, it's easier.
It becomes easier not to fall into old habits.
There's no easy way out of it.
It is just hard, hard practice.
And the resolution you make in the morning, and you keep repeating it through the day.
You can take just one thing.
Supposing there is a situation at work which is stressful.
This may be resentment or something.
So make a determination at the beginning of the day, I'm going to watch this, I'm not going to let it grab me, so I can keep cool, I can keep a certain objectivity about what's happening.
And then during the day, keep reinforcing that resolution, especially when you fall into that habit.
So you come out, you notice it, resolve it.
And that way you can
hopefully sustain a better objectivity about it.
And in that objectivity, in that clarity, usually some sort of solution arises.
You know, a small amelioration of the situation sometimes.
Often it's because we don't know how to talk to people.
We don't know how to approach them when they're messing with them out.
Or if we're in charge, we don't realize how we're messing them about.
We think they're messing us about, but actually we're messing them about.
There's a lot of that goes on.
There's a lovely book called Difficult Conversations which deals with all that.
It's a really cracker of a book.
One of the things that comes to mind is when something goes wrong, you see, everybody looks for blame.
You know, you did that, did you?
Right, you know.
Everybody looks for a scapegoat, somebody to sort of beat up.
But if you take out the personality and just look at the job, what went wrong with the job, right?
And then the question is, well, how do we get it right?
And that takes all the grief out of it.
Because now the person who's made a mistake doesn't feel they're going to be victimized, blamed, your fault.
But actually, there's a recognition that, well, maybe the person needs help.
Or recognition is just human failure.
I mean, you know, mistake.
Human mistake.
That's a real big breakthrough when you realize that blaming actually doesn't do anything at all.
If anything, it makes things much worse.
I mean, one has to presume that if a person has made a mistake, that they already feel guilt, shame, upset by it.
you know, afraid of consequences, you know, and if we're on the receiving end of blame and guilt, then of course you feel it, you see, and then in a sense you've got to accept that this person is deluded, that, you know, they're just looking for somebody to blame to get out, and you have to, in a sense, bear with that, and then to turn around and say, well, you know, how can I do it better, or how can you help me, or, you know, and if it's just a mistake, you just say, well, it's
human error.
What can you do, you know?
And then if they fire you can get the union on them.
It's a whole area of, oh boy, human relationship.
is contrition, is that contrition?
part of intuitive intelligence intuition, ah yeah right, excuse me well there is only one intelligence we only have one intelligence and that intelligence is that which knows, that which understands and
that is a quality of the Buddha the Buddha means the one who knows that's what it actually means, the one who knows, the Buddha and the qualities of the Buddha are satipaṁya that's why I call this place satipaṁya that mindfulness, moment to moment mindfulness being completely in the present being open to the present, no resistance and with it there's wisdom there's just this natural connection with things
now that is something which belongs to the unconditioned the Buddha in his victory verse that we chant every morning says I have achieved the unconditioned citta the unconditioned heart or mind asankhatam citta I've achieved that when that is engaging with the world it has to go through the mind, heart or body so it's thought
emotions, and action.
And that's your Eightfold Path.
Right understanding, right attitude, there's your heart, right action, right speech, right life business.
So, intuition, in this sense, is the Buddha Mind.
That's what it is.
It's that faculty which sees and understands the way things really are.
and that's one of his pet phrases to see and understand the way things really are jñāna-dāsanā yata-bhūtaṁ to see and understand to understand and see dāsanā how things have come to be in other words the process that's the literal translation you'll see it translated as how things are but actually the literal translation is which to me makes much more sense
to understand and see how things have come to be process so intuition is the intuitive intelligence in the definitions that I'm putting to it you know like the word intuition is often used for a feeling you know like you have an intuition about things yeah gut feeling that is this intuition that we're talking about
expressing itself at a non-intellectual level so for somebody who is very mental and thinks up there you see in a sense may not have that particular way of understanding because they're always coming through thought the intellect
and somebody who is at a more intuitional level in this sense of a connect feeling may not be able to express it often they have to express it through art or yeah I mean that's one of the definite that's one of the sort of divide between the masculine and the feminine you know
without saying men and women but it is a big problem between men and women if both are actually at the end of the scales at both ends of the scales it can be a bit of a disconnect I don't know whether you know this but looking at those two I used to know this very
She's died now, Beatrice.
She used to go to Dublin and stay in her house.
She was very old when I was teaching, when I'd go teaching there.
And she said to me that women, as she put it, think inductively and men deductively.
Now, I've probably got that wrong.
It's probably the other way around.
So the inductive way, if I've got that right,
is to go from the particular to the general.
And the other one is to go from the general to the particular.
So I said, oh, very interesting, Beatrice.
And it was at the time of the Afghan war.
We'd just gone into Afghanistan or something.
And we were talking about the war.
And as we were talking, I suddenly realized, and I said, Beatrice, we're doing it, aren't we?
yes so you just you just don't know you're doing it but that's the way you think so the masculine approaches from concepts from a generalization the big picture and when they come down to the specific they have a different view from somebody who's coming from the specific rising there to a general concept so in war
a masculine approach may be the big picture.
Well, look, you know, Al-Qaeda is a big danger, so we've got to go in there and sort them out.
And okay, we kill a few people, that's just collateral.
It's just one of those things that we have to do.
From the particular, the actual person getting killed, you see, where the other type of thinking, then you say, well, look, you know, this is suffering, this is killing people.
So therefore, we cannot go to war.
And there you get your huge contradictions.
And there we were, you see, arguing over a cup of tea.
And without, you know... And it wasn't that we were actually arguing over a point.
We just weren't understanding each other's position.
I mean, we were.
I could see where she was coming from and she understood where I was coming from.
But there was no...
It was difficult.
for me to entirely sympathize with her situation as it was with her to sympathize with mine not that I agree with collateral damage as a consequence but I was like the big picture so that form of intuition that's something else when normal people use it the way we're using it
in terms of the Buddha mind is your original intelligence the original mind before it the original faculty satipaṇya can you speak about gratitude and how it rises and what is it well it's a lovely it's a beautiful mental state isn't it to be thankful
And it just fills your heart with joy, doesn't it?
Especially when somebody has done something in a very thoughtful, kind way, completely unasked.
And I suppose what it is that's touching you is their love, isn't it?
Their caring, their sympathetic joy to be joyous with you.
And of course that
that increases your feeling of self-worth, of your feeling of goodness within you, isn't it?
When somebody either praises you or gives you something.
It's a way, really, of embracing the other, isn't it?
I mean, just think when you give something to somebody, you know, in that very clear, generous way.
And then, of course, there's what they give.
It's helped.
It's done something for us.
So the natural response of the heart is to feel thankful.
Gratitude.
And I think that when we feel that, it's easier for us to feel generous on our part.
That's why I always start the metta with people who've helped us.
Now, that's how we start in the monastic order.
We always thank.
Here it's been translated as our benefactors.
but the chat to Dayaka, the supporters, who give us our four requisites.
Food, clothing, shelter and medicine.
Those are your four basic requisites in anybody's life.
It's not just a monastic requisite.
You're not destitute if you can have those four, are you?
If you've got enough food, enough clothing, enough shelter and medicine.
You're not actually destitute.
I would say that people who don't have that are destitute as opposed to being poor.
That's an awful state to be in.
So yeah, that's I think gratitude.
And to complete that little virtuous circle, you have renunciation.
Because when you give, you give up something that you could have used for yourself.
And renunciation is the path.
you know, like ultimately we've got to renounce everything, got to let go of everything, you know.
Oh yeah, yeah, absolutely, time and wealth isn't it?
You give up your time and wealth, whatever you can, yeah.
as a sort of, like a virtuous circle, you just keep going round it, you see.
And the funny thing is, isn't it, I mean the paradox is, that when you do give with a good heart, it increases your own joy.
Because you've not only got your joy in the giving, in letting go, in seeing the joy of others, but also in seeing the joy of others, you know, the way it's helped them.
That's why, one of the reasons why, we're not supposed to say thank you.
Buddhist monks aren't supposed to say thank you.
Because it undermines your gift, because you may be saying it for the thank you.
So sometimes when, well, one of the things that upsets people is if somebody doesn't say thank you.
See?
So you've put a condition on the giving.
So the next time you give something, somebody says thank you, you see.
You just watch the mind.
I'm not going to give him.
Yeah, and it's something that you can develop by just
you know, going back through your lives and just seeing what you've been given.
I mean, the amount of stuff that society gives us is absolutely incredible, which people don't, you know, I mean, even now I go down to the doctor and I'm not paying for that, you know.
It's all been paid for out of the national purse.
The dentist, go right back to my early education, you know.
And it's all paid out of the sort of general purse.
Everybody whinges.
It's not good enough.
And they don't contemplate that all this stuff is just given without question.
I mean, like in education, obviously the education system is trying to do you, trying to get you to do the best you can.
But there's no penalty for not doing the best you can.
There's no penalty for not
arriving at some great academic stages.
See, same for me.
I go to Sri Lanka.
I'm greeted, I'm fed, I'm given shelter, medicine, robes, and nobody comes round knocking on the door and says, are you meditating or what?
Where have you got now?
How far have you got?
What jnana are you on?
Then they have a big meeting and say, well, he's not doing anything.
Kick him out.
It's funny, isn't it?
The only thing that is really asked is that, you know, generally you keep the rule.
Once you start breaking the rule in any serious way, then of course people do stop supporting you.
There's one question here I'll leave for another time because I need to look up a few things.
It's about Mara.
Can you explain what you mean by feeling emotions in the head?
Well, I think that's a sort of a more masculine thing.
Again, not saying men or women.
It's a bit of a more masculine thing.
It's to do with
it's a funny thing but it's as though the masculine type feels emotions up here in the head and when they go in the body there's nothing there yeah now I know this was very true for me because one of the one after I had a certain breakthrough I can't remember what it was now I remember this question coming up which is a very strange question for the feminine type the question was what is an emotion
I hadn't actually felt an emotion, even though it was obvious I was angry, sad, the whole lot, but I hadn't actually felt an emotion.
What was it?
And it was only through meditation that finally I got in contact with the body and the emotions started coming through as felt things.
I know it's very strange.
It's in the head, isn't it?
It's in the head.
to express it
That's right.
Yeah.
Well, it's definitely... No, no, it's...
But it is, I mean, that's the...
And what you do is, of course, by coming off thought, constantly through the meditation, coming into the body, eventually, of course, it does begin to come through the body.
That's what happens, you begin to feel it through the body.
Can it be to do with, like, a blockage, say, in the system, or is it something you try to do?
Conditioning, yeah.
I mean, it...
I think it's because we're so headbound.
Our whole attention is within thoughts and images.
We're a very headbound society.
I think other more less developed societies, so to speak, are probably much closer to their heart.
Well, in fact, there's a very good example of that, isn't there?
You know when the tsunami came?
all the animals left the beach you know they all went off but the humans still stood there and in the Andaman Islands the people there also still had that connection to nature and went off they just felt it in the air something wrong and they went off either they felt it like the animals directly that there was something out there coming towards them or they felt the
the fear coming from the animals themselves.
But one way or the other, none of them got touched by it.
That's what I read.
And, you know, in our very, I don't know, intellectualized society, you know, words, newspapers, reading is, you know, it sort of lifted us up into this weird cloud.
And I think that's one of the great gifts of meditation.
And even therapies, therapies do it, is to bring you back into the body.
Body-centered therapy.
And then, of course, you know, the insight is to realize that it's thought that's actually developing this stuff.
And that's when you start coming off thought.
I mean, you know, silly thought, this running away thought.
Every time, you know, like it's a constant effort, every time you see your mind wandering off somewhere, getting into an argument, you know, talking, note it, come back, just keep coming back, no matter what the resistance is, no matter how much you want to go there, just keep coming back into the present, into the body.
And to be clear, that's not suppressing or repressing anything, so long as you are aware of the emotional energy that's actually causing it.
Could you say something about the dharmas?
Can they be understood as universal laws or getting to different types of dharma confusion, is it?
Dharma has various meanings.
I don't mean the dharma with the big D. Oh, dharmas, it just means elements actually.
It's translated as elements, the different dharmas.
That chant we do in the morning, sabbe dhamma natati, you see, that's everything.
Every little thing.
And of course things are not real in themselves.
It's just pointing to elements.
I think it was translated as elements.
Elements of things.
Are we talking about air, water?
Yeah.
Well, those are the four great elements, as they call them, the Mahabhuta, the great elements.
But I think it goes into all sorts of things.
I'll sort of check that out, look it up.
Well, you know, it's the elements that go into some greater whole.
So you're constantly breaking things down into dharmas, little dharmas.
Just as time is broken down into these little moments that we call kalapas.
That's the word for it.
Yeah.
I mean, that's why we say to go like the Kalapas.
Sorry.
When you talk about mindfulness of the Dhammas, is it about mindfulness of these constituent elements?
Yes, of everything.
Right.
Of everything.
The bits.
Yeah, the bits.
Every time you deconstruct something, it turns into a Dhamma.
as I say I'll come back to that I'll try and make that more I'll make this the last one as these anti what's that word or wholesome approach that can be used in conjunction with the tendency anti
antidotes got it antidotes yeah are these antidotes a wholesome approach or wholesome or are there oh sorry are there antidotes a wholesome approach that can be used in conjunction with the tendencies of personality that
it's not that bad actually that and that you described on Monday night in the talk laws the W laws is it W of personality is that it's a killer isn't it that
It looks like a W and a 6.
I can't work that one out.
Definitely laws, I've got that.
The W and the 6.
I'll make that last question.
Are there antidotes for a horse?
I've made a mistake actually, that's why.
Are there antidotes or wholesome approaches that can be used in conjunction with the tendencies of personality that we have and that you described on Monday night in the talk?
The tendencies, yes.
The anusaya.
Are there... Yeah.
Well, the antidote, not surprisingly, is to do the opposite.
Basically.
So, the antidote to...
you know feeling stinginess is to be generous do the opposite but all we have to be careful of is not to be aggressive towards the negative within us that's the mistake we make we make a judgement about it that's bad that's negative it's just the conditioning doesn't mean to say it's not wholesome but it's when we say I'm bad and then you sort of make that identity with it
and that's harmful and then you do the opposite you do the opposite take anything anything which you can see is unwholesome and just look at the opposite and that's what you do but you've got to be in some things you have to be slightly careful about the opposite I'm thinking here of lust
so the antidote to lust is to look at the disgusting nature of the body and that definitely undermines it but if you keep doing that you get really disgusted and it's very depressing so in certain antidotes you sort of do it to sort of balance it out you see and then they sort of disappear food the antidote to overeating is to just
imagine what's happening to your food going through your system and what it ends up as exactly see and if you follow every mouthful down there it definitely undermines your greediness right but eventually if you keep doing that you stop eating because it's so disgusting so you know like you've got to with any of these more visceral habits we have just do the opposite but you just have to be careful when it comes to
virtues then of course that doesn't pertain because there's no limit to generosity there's always got to be wisdom there's a lovely story about Saint Francis actually Saint Francis said give everything away give everything away and he himself only had these rag robes if you ever go to Assisi just go and see it really is very moving especially for somebody in Buddhism and knows the life story of the Buddha because his robes are there
And it is actually a patchwork, higgledy-piggledy patchwork sackcloth.
That's what he wore.
He just picked up all bits of sackcloth and sewed them all together.
Yeah, it's quite moving.
And one of his brothers came back with no clothes.
He'd given his robe away.
So he had to make a rule.
You can give everything away but not your robe.
So you've got to be slightly intelligent about these things.
That's a great story, that.
so I think we'll leave that there for this evening but there are quite a few so maybe I'll carry on tomorrow just finish them off and see if I can answer that other question I'd like to just look it up it's about Mara the evil one
So I can only hope our little discussions and question answering has been of some assistance.
May you be fully liberated from all suffering sooner rather than later.